the quotient of two polynomials a of X
and B of X can be written in the form a
of x over B of X is equal to Q of X plus
R of X over B of X where Q of X and R of
X Q of X and RN X and R of X are
polynomials and the degree of R of X is
less than the degree of B of X write the
quotient 7x to the 6 plus X to the third
plus 2x plus 1 over x squared in this
form well this one is pretty
straightforward because we're dividing
by x squared so you could literally view
this as 7x to the 6 divided by x squared
plus X to the third divided by x squared
plus 2x divided by x squared plus 1
divided by x squared so we could just do
this term by term what's 7x to the sixth
divided by x squared well X to the 6
divided by x squared is X to the fourth
so it's going to be 7x to the fourth
power and then same thing right over
here plus X to the third divided by x
squared well that's just going to be X
so plus X and then we're going to have
2x divided by x squared but remember we
want to write it in a form of R of x
over B of X where R of x has a lower
degree than B of X well 2 of a 2x has a
lower degree than x squared here this is
a degree 1 this is degree 2 so you could
write it as plus 2x over x squared like
that and then you could write plus 1
over x squared so you could do this plus
1 over x squared so you could write it
like that but that's not exactly the
form that they want they want is to
write it Q of X and that could be you
could view that as 7x to the fourth plus
X and then they want to plus R of x over
B of X so plus some polynomial over x
squared in this case so instead of
writing it as 2x over x squared plus 1
over x squared we could just write it as
2x plus 1 over x squared so one way to
think about it so let me just put some
parentheses here so that it interprets
my typing correctly so notice this part
of the Pala know
these these terms have an equal or
higher degree than x squared so I just
divided those 7x is 6 divided by x
squared is 7x to the fourth X to the 3rd
divided by x squared is X and then once
I got two terms that had a lower degree
the next squared I just left them there
I just said plus whatever 2x plus 1
divided by x squared is and that's the
form that they wanted us to write it in
we'll check our answer and we got it
right